n
inside jokes that's part of the
joy showing up and doing this
every day part of the joy also
Dana is that we get to talk
about stories that at times are
wildly entertaining and I
cannot get enough
of this story about the vice
president kamala Harris, we
played a clip of this on the
show yesterday before a detail
leaked out about
the contacts. But this was the
vice president meeting with
some children talking about
discovery and NASA and outer
space. And she was talking to
them people are joking like she
like had a lot of animals and
they all hitter at once
she was really feeling herself
in this clip, it's even more
amazing to watch which we can't
do hear on the radio and the
kids are due to flee sitting
there listening issues wraps
and I sing about space and
discovery or what have you.
This is what it sounded like
just as a reminder cut 3.
>> To think about so much
that's ear that we still have
to. And I
love that. I love them and some
very excited about space
Council we're going to learn so
much as we increasingly I think
are serious and interesting and
the potential for
the discoveries and where you
can do in space so that's one
of the things I'm most excited
about.
>> And she goes on at
one point I'm telling it's
going to be unbelievable you
can see the moon with your own
eyes
and the kids are like whoa,
she's talking to them like
they're 5. They looked like
there may be 12 to 13 so
there's to the awkwardness
there and then we learned last
night.
That these were not kids from
some local school that was my
assumption alike the science
club for one local DC schools
came in to learn about this and
it's a youtube series called
get curious with vice president
Harris. These were actually
child actors who had to dish an
for these parts and they booked
these parts to show up and play
average kids which is probably
why they look so engaged and in
thrall as opposed to slightly
creeped out by this woman.
I don't understand what the
thought process was here to
have paid child actors come in
for this.
It makes it even more hilarious
to me Dana I think that's the
thing that we should all do it
does we just you just have to
laugh this is my very favorite
shows that the last several
years as veep.
>> I managed to everybody like
this. Yes happened on beat.
What happened and then when the
White
responded today when the vice
president's office responded
thirst statement with something
like we had no idea that this
was happening we had no nothing
to do with the child actors.
>> We didn't think you had a
clue about any of it I mean
that is a pattern that we're
seeing over and over again.
You know they you know anything
they hired an image consultant
to help her see more relay
double and in order to do that
they had to hire child actors.
And also guide you know that
this was all happening she
actually filmed this on the day
where Afghanistan was falling
apart.
It was that day I was I can't
remember the exact date but as
you as one of those days, I'm
trying to find my notes right
here. Yes, one of those but
like well like those days where
you're thinking. Oh my gosh
this. You see everything a
disintegrating kids getting
kicked out of girls getting
kicked out of school things
like that. I hear it is right
here it is right here in the
actors in bring the kid actors
in here and they're going
>> and eyes. The vice president
talks about outer space.
>> But here's the just laugh
about it. Right so they use
taxpayer dollars but only for
the best part. But the best
part. name of the production I
love this.
>> Sinking ship entertainment.
>> This
is BP even even the writers and
they can they come up
with this.
>> It's not fun night in
American they're not even
American action monto how about
that. Their Canadian group
America's second ship America's
I brought these kids in and
there's 1 one of the child
actors I think is 13.
And then his agent called and
said hey you booked the gig and
the gig was to come and pretend
to be interested
at the Naval Observatory with
kamala Harris carrying on with
these children, I guess.
Did you notice the other part
of that Dan aware.
It's like she site yourself up
to talk to kids and had
sort of a mismatch in her brain
of the tone.
Yeah age group because you talk
to tweens or adolescence very
differently than first graders,
but she was going first grader
with the tweens I think you
want to put some person for her
it has been for a long time
that she doesn't seem
authentic.
>> And you saw that in the
focus of don't take that for
this is from Democratic voters.
That there was an authenticity
probe problem and you saw his
phone over and over again.
They don't do her any favors.
But as an image consultant say
no this one might be a really
great way to make her seem
relay double by hiring child
actors and put in a position
where she's not comfortable.
So what do you get for for this
they're gonna put this on a
youtube channel. What voter
exactly what voter constituency
are you going for but you
actually care about you know
have any idea what's going on
in this country. Guy have to
say that I just find it
mystifying that somebody who
achieves this incredible
accomplishment of becoming the
first woman vice president
is basically not doing anything
with the power of the office.
And and I I lot of people
might think that whatever she
would do on the border might
not be what they want. But at
least you could admire her for
trying. She literally is doing
nothing. That you can see.
There's nothing tangible and I
think what a waste of an
opportunity. I because
I would like to say to her in
first like.
Just do it like for example
when
those 3 guys in a Biden
administration went down to
Mexico last week to talk about
the immigration problem.
And she didn't go and she's
supposed to be in charge of the
issue. There's no way I want to
let them go without me, you
know I would have said
actually you guys are invited
to ride on my plane.
I will be leading the
delegation and you can brief me
while we are on our way there
because the president put her
in charge of this that was
Biden's decision I don't think
she wants to be in charge of it
I think she'd much rather do
this with with get carry us.
>> I have to note by Dana,
all up on it writing and hot
air had a very funny take on
this It is straight out of the
PE he said you needed child
actors because she was acting
so out there
in her conversation this does
painfully phony weird af act
that normal school kids would
have been looking at each other
with side. I what the health is
this woman talking about she
needed people who are really
professionals to pretend like
everything was normal
and good and they did a very
good job in one of the kids was
quoted saying oh, she's says
she's very charming she's very
charismatic and all up and said
well he would have to say that
if he wants to land the role
and get
curious too. The sequel from a
sinking ship productions.
But didn't you mentioned.
The vice president not really
asserting herself on the border
or really on anything she seems
to have been sidelined by the
president's team, but also self
sidelining in some way yeah,
the president meanwhile
is not taking questions almost
ever we ran through some of the
stats yesterday, the RNC
went back and looked at the
tape he has not taken a
question on Afghanistan and 32
days, he's done one sit-down
interview as you know when you
put a principal in the
president whomever down you sit
them down for a one on
one interview. That interview
or that journalist has an
opportunity to really go back
and forth and dig deeper in and
ask follow-ups he has exposed
himself or subjected himself to
that type of grilling.
One time in the last almost
3 months. Obviously this is a
strategy that they have decided
on they've landed on it saying
I guess the president defending
himself and making his case
would do more harm and
therefore we are going to
shield him from questions as
often as possible what do you
make Dana of that strategy.
>> I think it's terrible I met
them I think that is helping
him but look at the poll
numbers there in free fall.
So it seems back the White
House is floundering and also
what happened to return to
norms I thought we were
returning to norms.
And the norms is that the
president takes questions from
the press president Trump to
questions all the time. And
even though the press. The
mainstream media really
couldn't stand him. They love
the fact that they had access
to him and
because they seemed to try to
treat president Biden with kid
gloves, they're not complaining
about no access. I have to tell
you if I was White House press
secretary. I can imagine during
the Bush administration of
President Bush and take
questions for this long on such
an important topic that is of
great national interest.
I would have heard about it
from the white House
correspondents correspondents
Association. It may be getting
down my door but also I would
have wanted to help provide
that however.
I just prefer a president who
never would put me in that
position.
As much as you think the staff
will lead and the let him look
he's in charge. He is the
commander in chief, he gets
to decide and dry Murdoch of
national review had a really
good piece of it.
She said Biden is in charge
like a lot maybe people might
think that everybody else is
running the show but that lets
him off too easily.
Yeah, he loves he's making the
decision not to talk to the
press. He knows he should talk
to the press and that's why he
always says oh they told me not
to take questions. So that he
can blame somebody else.
And it's not just Afghanistan.
It's the border mean there are
multiple concurrent crises.
He's presiding over all of
them.
>> And he'd aims to take a
question here there every so
often with very few follow-up
see often snaps that reporters
who might shout a question
at him. It's not a great look
to
put it very mildly but it is
what they've landed on as
there. Their tactical footing
moving forward here and
it isn't going well, but I
guess their fear is it could go
even worse the more he talks
and that's the calculation
apparently that they have made
thus far Dana Perino we've got
to let you go I caring for the
5 coming up in just over an
hour on FOX News Channel we
always love chatting with you